[موسيقى]
يصل إلى السماء ما لا يقل عن
3000 عمود يقف شامخًا من الوادي
أدناه لإنشاء غابة شاهقة من
الحجر الرملي تقع حديقة شانغ جيا جي
للغابات الوطنية في مقاطعة هونان
الغربية في الصين وعلى بعد أكثر من 600
ميل من  المدن الرئيسية في
شنغهاي وبكين
[موسيقى]
قد يجد عشاق أفاتار جيمس كاميرون
هذه الركائز الصخرية مألوفة ، فقد كانت
مصدر إلهام
لعالم باندورا الأسطوري في الفيلم ،
نتجت هذه الركائز عن الطقس على مدى
سنوات عديدة ومزيج من
الفصول المتغيرة والنباتات  التي تنمو
عليها ساهمت في أشكالها الفردية
والفريدة
على الرغم من أن الفصول تغير الطقس
رطبًا على مدار السنة مما ينتج عنه
أوراق شجر كثيفة في الواقع 98 في المائة من
الحديقة مغطاة بالنباتات وهناك
مسارات للمشي لمسافات طويلة متاحة لرؤية هذه
الغابة المذهلة
ولكن  بما أن جيمس كاميرون لا يعرف شيئًا
مضغوطًا يجربها في
السماء
[موسيقى]
أنت